[Music]
and so uh has everybody been hearing
about this [ __ ] biggest storm that's
hit the uk in recent years called storm
arwin no what a dumb name you know it's
a literal storm
[Laughter]
actual weather storm when stuff starts
like that they go this thing's storming
london usually it's not a literal story
it's like a trend
it's like halle berry all right anyways
um so
a huge storm named storm
our wind has hurricane
like a storm yeah like a weather storm
like whatever whatever you would learned
in like fourth grade about storms that
precipitation
hail
the weather
would you say stormy like a sexual storm
what other
stars what other storms could there be
is the tornado in like a penis form
that's just coming in and out there's
not a tree now i want to know is it
sucking things yeah
it's the eye of the storm
things after it throws
um so yeah the storm's going crazy over
a quarter million people have like lost
power grids and electricity and stuff
like that um
people have died and whatnot but
specifically there's a group of people
that have been trapped in britain's
highest pub since friday evening here
here comes the upside
6th of november enjoying [ __ ] the pub
enjoying lovely karaoke nights as they
spend their nights inside the 17th
century uh style so they're just stuck
in a bar because the storm happened
while they were drinking yeah and
they're like look can't go to work might
as well just keep drinking damn they
actually are there to celebrate a band
called no asis which is a tribute to
oasis no oasis they're they're it's
amazing it's amazing anthony did you
name that band no i swear that's really
good right now we're here this is
anthony part of the article i'm a fan no
he's just promoting his band
no aces get it
so they get trapped in there they've got
makeshift beds couches they you know
they're like quizzing each other
watching films on the big projectors
pretty much [ __ ] paradise it's
paradise slash hateful late i'm sure uh
they're being served a buffet meal with
what's like left in the in the
restaurant and stuff but ultimately
they're snowed in
is there a tab that they're all gonna
have to pay at the end of this whole
[ __ ] because that would oh that would be
sure either that or like they continue
to stay snowed in and then eventually
cannibalism
oh yeah that's good that's also you know
the owner's not saying anything about
tabs he's not even bringing it up he's
all just eat up yeah and then once they
open the doors here's your tab here's
your attack there's your [ __ ] racking
up the bill dude
it doesn't sound kind of fun though it
wouldn't be like oh yeah [ __ ] fun too
obviously we're not going to [ __ ]
have one week slumber party by choice
one of these in the pub oh dude i always
wanted to get stuck in an elevator whoa
that sucks that's like the worst case
scenario cause you always hear those
stories you're like oh man i wish that
happened to me just so i could know what
it feels like you you're the only one
dude how are you gonna you gotta [ __ ]
and piss with your friends in the
elevator it's kind of fun
okay i'm on board okay how long were you
how long were you i think ours was like
five or six hours oh
it was on yeah the the it was with
quests the whole crew the quest crew
from the movies there was go i found it
and you could move the tires it just got
the main thing is it gets super [ __ ]
hot because when elevators truly shut
down then so does the ventilation system
so did you guys just get naked with each
other no we actually didn't but
where did you get but the crazy thing is
we we actually inside edition covered it
because we had video of the whole thing
and then they they got they bought it
from us and made a segment about us
being stuck in the elevator where it
does suck damn you guys make money no
matter what it was it was after uh we
got stuck in an elevator it was cal
state fullerton it was like after the
show and then we were gonna take the
elevator the meet and greet and then we
just went
because there's too many people in it
well thank god there were people like
waiting for you because they're like
where do they go yeah do six hours or
whatever because they don't you like
even if you can open it you have to have
the fire department come and do it but
did they know you were stuck immediately
yeah did you did you press the button oh
[ __ ] how did you find that so fast
through the elevator
way too many people in the elevator man
the reality of it is just uncomfortable
like it's like at first it's fun and
it's like hilarious and then did you get
claustrophobic
no i didn't but a couple of other guys
did dude no one had a pee
i i mean i don't we didn't get that far
so that five hours five hours a long
time
it's a little longer than i remember it
could it was it was a long last time
though it's probably like 30 minutes
yeah
half an hour these people exaggerate so
much
actually it wasn't really stuck
there's one guy by the elevator just
keeping the door closed
it was a weight limit issue yeah there
were too many people in it too many fat
bucks yeah
also those things aren't lying because i
always read it and i'm like man i'm just
[ __ ] right but every time it it's too
heavy it beeps it goes big
maybe it did but village campuses they
always have the sketchiest elevators
like all the colleges i went to
like elevators were always breaking down
the worst in china that's that's when i
got stuck in it
so in china they don't give a book about
maximum capacity it's just a matter of
like can you get in the elevator or not
right so literally every single time
it's like the subway in japan you know
what i'm saying people are just trying
to make the cut and i remember there was
one time we were at our old partner
studio and the the literal capacity
thing says 16 people
and uh all of us are trying to bum rush
and get into the elevator and we all get
in and it's already kind of hella packed
and we're all standing there and then
mike's song comes late right he looks
and he's like uh i'm not gonna get that
right i'm like nah dude [ __ ] it let's go
it's all right [ __ ] he gets in and
then literally like once the door closes
after a couple of seconds it's just and
just like stops halfway down and we're
stuck in that we're gonna be stuck here
for like 40 minutes right but at the
first moment when we get stuck
everybody's like yo what happened are we
over capacity and then i look up
and i'm like
16 people i look back and i start
counting like
i look at mike i'm like
oh dude
you
[Laughter]
it's totally my fault for telling him to
do that but yeah so how did it open we
ended up standing there for [ __ ] uh
like probably 30 minutes to 45 minutes
also really claustrophobic and like some
people get really uncomfortable and when
somebody else is really uncomfortable
right no matter how like it's [ __ ]
uncomfortable what floor are you guys
trying to get to we were already on the
18th floor and then we got stuck in like
the 16th and a half it like went down a
little bit and then just got someone
trying to pry it open we tried to but
where the half and you can't really open
it and then like this everyone always
does that that [ __ ] don't work that [ __ ]
don't work i love to found it yeah as if
you can't see the line that's a square
that signals that this is this is a door
that might be some hollywood [ __ ] that
we're like oh for the movie we need
somebody to be able to get somebody in
the elevator and it's probably not real
does that actually always work is there
really an openable latch always there
there is but it's always covered now
it's covered by like a great or like a
or whatever they cover it can't tell
that it is a hatch yeah they're like too
many [ __ ] spy movies ruining this
right and how come it's always up why
not down like why down that and go with
that so you just drop right to the
bottom
joe let me let me let me give you a
visual demonstration of why it's not on
the bottom because if it's on the bottom
and the elevator happens to go down
then you're going to see yourself smash
and then it benefits up you can hold on
to the rope yeah because i would go down
and then i would swing
to the other door oh yeah like a monkey
bar what are you what are you not
everybody could do that though only the
high-class elevators have swings on the
bottom
oh my god
i think i think the best place to get
stuck is the amazon distribution center
oh so like in the zombie apocalypse i'm
headed there is there food there though
yeah they have everything everything
everything they got
have everything there that's what they
have yeah gingerbread noodles
way better than non-shim dude really yup
they got food
they got [ __ ] they got jabba they
have weapons weapons
they probably have they have blow up
mattresses and blankets
yeah yeah vibrators does amazon have
blood they got everything just they got
vibrators i bet they have the dark
knight
the dark knight the dark knight blow up
doll no have you heard of the dark
knight the dark knight oh dude we gotta
show it we gotta show it it's a jack off
machine that's amazing no dark knight
the dark knight
you could suction cup it against the
wall and it [ __ ] you this isn't the
dark knight but this is funny on amazon
why why do people still [ __ ] buy
these because it's cheap because cleanup
is easy
is it though well that's my question
with with sex dolls is clean up
you just hold it down is that but you
just squeeze it but then you take it
outside the hose and then someone knows
that you have a you have a sex doll or
they're disposable or you shower with it
yeah
those expensive ones though
because then you you use vagina for one
and round two the mouth and then you
eventually get to clean it because if
you don't clean it and um your spooge
dries it'll get scratchy
and then your penis will get all like
scratched up and so you need to clean it
but i don't understand they never
describe how you how you clean it that
part's on you man yeah it's like do you
have to stick your finger in with like a
microfiber towel probably oh i think
they have a detachable [ __ ]
i would design it that way you gotta
look for the deluxe ones you ever typed
in deluxe sex dolls those are just
people
those are rubber people yeah to a level
we're like wait these are just humans
the package comes in it's like moving
and breathing you're like hello
they're making them with ai now right
but i always think like you know that's
too much bro yeah how are you gonna like
program the ai because it's nerds
programming list yeah so there's gonna
be no challenge you're not gonna get a
challenge because the nerds gonna be
like no they have to say yes all the
time all the time
no matter what i say yes yes yes yes
it's not gonna be fun like do this
position yes do this position yes you
want some challenge no
it's gonna be like i would really say a
no every ninth time yeah
i just gotta ask you eight more times
yeah
i don't know like i think the
programmers
they have to have like quote unquote
cool people programming the dialogue
just so like it feels real the nerds
never get laid either
i hate this robot
it's too real
someone made this too difficult
friendzoned me
i told you not to hire tony he's too
cool
or anthony lee
anthony lee programs he's gonna have sex
with all the [ __ ] haters
you